my biggest
thing that i like to do is discover
stuff
and not necessarily things that have
already been discovered i really like to
discover things that haven't been
discovered yet if you take an asteroid
and you discover an asteroid for example
even though there's half a million of
them out there that's one you found
nobody else in the world knew about that
asteroid before you saw it
what i've been doing here lately and and
for about 15 16 years now
i've been working with near-earth
objects
my observations contribute to making
sure that we don't have something coming
up that's going to fall on our heads
kind of first got into it probably 10 12
years old i was begging begging begging
to get a telescope and you know we were
in a very rich family so it took a while
to get it and one christmas i got
telescope then i started using it and i
got aperture fever
you want bigger telescopes all the time
so i started learning how to build them
i learned how to how to work in a
machine shop
i can build things that i wanted to
build
and a lot of that was astronomy parts
i kind of modified my life to fit this
study this kind of lifelong study
sandlot is
a
very tiny little observatory it's only
ten foot by ten foot wide
the telescope i built uh over a period
of about a year and a half and it may
not look very polished
it works really well
i'm good with that
i have i don't have a degree in
astronomy
i have a passion for astronomy
and i've done it for many many years and
i've i've contributed i think to the
scientific body of astronomy that's
that's really kind of a
yeah from that standpoint i am an
astronomer
listen
this sound is the first evidence of the
big bang
and this is a story of two radio
astronomers who discovered proof of the
beginning of everything
this is the horn reflector antenna at
bell laboratories robert can you tell us
what this thing does it receives radio
waves coming from the direction it's
pointed to
and funnels them into a receiver that's
robert wilson radio astronomer in the
early 60s he and his colleague arno
penzias were tasked with measuring the
brightness of the sky using the horn
reflector antenna but no matter where
they pointed it the antenna read a much
larger signal than the pair expected our
immediate reaction was that there must
be something wrong with our system they
thought it might be interference from
the horn itself or new york city or even
some pigeons living in the horn you know
we thought about a collection of
ordinary sources that are in the very
distance that just didn't seem to be
possible so they reached out to a group
of researchers at princeton university
led by astrophysicist robert dickey who
had been scouring the sky unsuccessfully
for evidence of the big bang arnold
called and
dickie picked up the phone and they
started hearing things like atmospheric
radiation sky brightness
all the things that they were working on
dickie put the phone down and said boys
we've been scooped
robert and arno had measured what dickie
and his team were searching for the
elusive cosmic microwave background
radiation
he thought about a big bang source of
the universe
realized that it would be very hot and
therefore full of radiation
and as the universe expanded that
radiation would simply cool
and whereas it was
extremely hot to start with by now it
would simply be
microwaves now it's so cold that it
would just be radio waves
and this nut pigeons or the noisy city
was exactly what had been causing
headaches for robert wilson and arno
penzias the two groups of researchers
from bell labs and princeton each wrote
complementary research papers with their
findings they wrote one about the theory
we wrote one about our measurement and
we published them i think unlike many
changes that occur in science there
really was a paradigm shift with very
little pushback
it was huge there was no evidence of a
new theory for the beginning of the
entire universe over a decade later
robert wilson and arno penzias were
awarded the 1978 nobel prize in physics
how'd that feel robert
felt pretty strange to win the nobel
prize i didn't feel comfortable being on
the same list with einstein but despite
robert's humility there's no doubt the
significance of the discovery it gives
us our earliest picture of the universe
from which we can extrapolate back to
very early times
as one of the centerpieces of cosmology
my name's tim ducette
i'm an amateur astronomer
and i'm also legally blind kind of an
oxymoron isn't it
it turns out
i can actually see the night sky better
than most people
probably better than you
when i was younger um it's it's easy to
become discouraged
you know realizing that you're never
going to drive a car
that you'll never be an astronaut
at least that's what you're told
i was born with congenital cataracts
they remove the lenses of my eyes and
widen my pupils
that left me with only about 10 of my
eyesight
for the average person their pupil
automatically adjusts for the amount of
light coming in it opens and closes
but for me my
pupil is open so it's always letting in
a lot of light
during the day
i see everything extremely
bright
everything is overexposed
colors are are more vivid
but at night time the tables are turned
and it's like a curtain has been lifted
when i was a teenager i went on some
additional surgery to improve my
eyesight
i got home from the hospital and i
looked up at the sky and at first i
thought i was actually having a detached
retina i was seeing millions of spots of
light
and realized that
that was the milky way i was looking at
and it was
phenomenal
at first i didn't really realize what
it had given me
i took 15 years later
to realize that
what i had was special
with my personal savings i built an
observatory on a hill near my house
and called it deep sky eye
when i'm looking through a telescope i'm
not wearing my glasses
and my eye is like a camera without a
lens
so it's focusing the light very clearly
onto my retina
i see a little bit extra light that most
people wouldn't see
you know you look at the orion nebula
and you know it looks like a fuzzy patch
but you know i kind of get a little bit
of purplish tinge to it
the sky here is like a tapestry of
interstellar
dust it looks like a velvet background
you know with diamonds all through it
it's absolutely amazing
my wife is also legally blind
she doesn't see very well at night but
most of the time when we're you know
walking or at the observatory i'll
explain to my wife what i'm seeing
she appreciates the night sky even
though she doesn't see it very well
when i look through the telescope or
look up at the night sky
it makes you realize really that all
your problems with fact that you're
legally blind or or whatever it really
just doesn't matter
you realize that you're a part of this
universe
there's a lot to love about living in a
big bright city
people
culture
late night food
but there's something missing
it's there but you can't see it
the night sky
this is the story about a small town in
colorado actually two small towns in
colorado that are devoted to space
westcliff has a population of 564
residents and silver cliff has a
population of 575.
this used to be a mining community and
then it evolved into a railroad
community and then into a ranching
community
we're always looking to do something
that will bring people into our
community and lately that seems to be we
need to invest in our sky
so they made live pollution their enemy
they darken their towns so that the
night sky could become their star
attraction have you ever seen the milky
way that goes from horizon to horizon
88 of the world's population has never
seen the milky way
it's the most magnificent thing in the
world that's what we see here
but for the towns to go dark they needed
to cover all of their lights
not just street lamps but the lights
outside every house and ranch near town
that wasn't easy this is a frontier town
and i can tell you
frontier people don't like being told
what to do
we had to win their hearts and minds
it took 10 years they passed ordinances
raised money to cover the street lights
and even build an observatory
and the darker the town became the more
people saw the light
this year the valley's dark sky was
designated as one of the darkest in the
world drawing visitors from all over
okay
might need a six-pack though
well i was really hoping we'd be able to
see saturn by now yeah me too
that a community would decide to dim its
lights and help everyone to appreciate
the beauty of the night sky is an
amazing thing
you come to a place like this
and
the stars just
burst
and it's remarkable
not a lot of people are lucky enough to
see the dark sky as our ancestors saw it
and i feel that we're a very special
place to be able to look at the stars as
people did thousands of years ago
it's a humbling thing suddenly you
realize you can almost touch it
and you're now a part of the bigger
universe
and so it's just a wonderful experience
to see the dark skies and that's what
we're trying to preserve
when you're looking up at a beautiful
dark night sky
what goes through my mind is the wonder
of it
it's just so incredibly vast
i never lose interest in it because it's
just so beautiful
i wanted others to enjoy the night sky
as much as they could
the best way to do that is to build your
own planetarium
the kovac planetarium is located
in the northwoods of wisconsin in a
little town of monaco
i began the project in 1997 and it was
finally open to the public in 2007
i started from scratch a lot of trial
and error i had no blueprints
there were many many times where i had
so many roadblocks come my way that i
wanted to give up
i just had to convince myself and my
neighbors that i wasn't crazy
and of course when i started putting up
this planetarium that was when people
really started to wonder about me
so it's kind of
neat and built this thing and now i get
to maintain it
keep it running for the shows
this is the largest mechanically
operated planetarium in the world
all the stars are hand-painted
one dot at a time with glow-in-the-dark
luminous paint
it took about five months
this is the only planetarium in the
whole world
that has the night sky as
glow-in-the-dark paint
this is beyond normal
but some of us actually put
our dream into reality and do it
i took ordinary materials and i made
something extraordinary out of them
you